hello and welcome to this video i'm
playing against balashnikov
wow c4b5 that's funny
um
what is this actually this is this is a
reversed
uh
this is a reverse wing gambit right
funny
um yeah
sicilian wing gambit reversed
yeah i i spent a moment because i
remember that that i actually looked at
b5 when i wrote this
the the original um english course in
2016
currently working on an updated
version of it
of course for chessable lifetime c4
knight f3
and just wondered i looked at it i
looked at b5 i
do look at stuff like that even though
it's probably not great but
it's still it's not so bad to to check
those
weird lines
black the way it turned out i played
i wasted a bit of time early on after
that i played quickly to not get into
huge time issues
um black has maybe some compensation
here i am it's got some active pieces
it's not um
[Music]
it's not totally ridiculous let's say
wants to go d5 i guess so so
how do we organize this maybe knight e2
bishop c3
well knight e2 is going to go knight e4
probably
ship c3 then queen moves here
i have an increment here so i don't have
to
be unduly panicking
with the time going down
taking on b2 is not good because of
bishop c3
here
yeah so this was my idea
and then knight to f4 maybe he just
takes it
on c3
yeah as mentioned this is not he has
some compensation in this position
maybe not enough but
it's
definitely not
absolutely nothing
so 92
to attack c6 i
wouldn't mind to trade the queen side
against the c6
pawn
i'm also with 92 threatening knight d4
so it's not such an easy thing here for
him
like rook b8 knight d4 rook b2 knight
takes c6
should be excellent for white
yeah i still have 94.
maybe b4 now stopping c5 and if he takes
a3 i'm still taking c6
okay
wow really
i can also take with the knight here
knight takes queen form
yeah rook takes is also good for white
this is why i was hesitating a little
bit
unbelievable that this is that this
should be possible
okay i can take g6 but i can also check
him
it must be devastating come on cannot be
that cannot work
bishop f8 i can simply take yeah
yeah now that was a bit too much
he got some compensation though i mean
absolutely
um okay so d4 that's the same recipe
as usually played in the um
in the wing gambit but there is a
difference i have that extra move
takes which actually allows knight c6
so with hindsight maybe this isn't
actually the best
the engine just says e4
you know develop stuff it's often good
just treat it like an e4 e5 opening
where
for some reason this this has been
played
yeah yeah that's true but
um the way it turned out i think black
black's position wasn't so bad i mean as
you see the engine
even though this is just a super
shallow analysis depth is giving black
some compensation
and um here i think slowly i'm
consolidating
and and should be a bit better
this is maybe a good move here the
engine approves
like allowing bishop here maybe here
just like improve the position
black can never take as this is
leading to a devastating situation on
the
on the king side knight e4
bishop here i didn't mind that
and now i think that this seems fine
yeah like
pile up yeah i'm hitting many top moves
here
so this one and now i'm not sure knight
e2 i like that rook cc2 is
the the most obvious move but i thought
this should be fine
yeah and the engine does agree i mean i
saw that if he
plays like that i get this
and this must be very good for me
because those pawns are still
weak and probably one of them will drop
and i have the active pieces with the
knight on one side of the board so
this is um usually favorable queen and
knight
on one side of the board is usually
better than queen and bishop on one side
of the board
so that is indeed good maybe it wasn't
the best but
yeah but he played rook a6 and now this
looks
fantastic really b4 is good yeah
so i think i did reasonably well there
in this game
take take rook c4 that wasn't the best
okay rook a6 looks better
so i should play b1 yeah
keep the pawn prepare b5 okay
yeah that was much more precise but f5
is insane i mean that that must be
terrible
because you're not you're now just going
down to an attack
[Music]
this was the game
and something like that you can never
survive that's not possible
oh yeah he steps into all kinds of forks
already
this is medium
nice mate next move whatever you do h4
or takes on f4 is made okay guys thanks
for watching